what I want to do was uh actually start
I'm not going to tell you just yet what
will be the particular area like the
heading we're going to make just yet I
actually want to go to the syllabus
which you can see in front of you I've
just taken an excerpt of just one page
out of it and can I just ask um either
of you have either of you downloaded the
syllabus for extension 2 or extension
one for that matter
um yeah I printed it out and I just keep
it at the back that's that's so good
okay well look I mean
um there's no obligation to do this but
because especially this is a document
that's it's actually not uh you're not
the primary audience of this document
teachers are the primary audience of
this document and so you know you don't
have to read this however I particularly
think with this course because you guys
are doing a lot of the learning
independently it is super valuable to
always have like you said you know Sean
you mentioning that you have access to
it and you can check across it because
then you'll always know that you've got
a comprehensive set of like I've learned
all the things it's a fantastic way to
go back and study and make sure you have
covered everything and the other thing
that is very very useful is that I think
it's going to sound a bit wild but you
know the textbooks that we use right and
the textbooks that you've used for many
many years they were written this is
going to sound silly they'll run by
human beings and they're written by
human beings number one who are they
make mistakes just like all human beings
do and number two this one's more
important actually they're written by
human beings who didn't write the
syllabus in 99 of cases right so what
would happen is say for example me right
I could decide one day I would like to
write a textbook right and what I would
do is I would look at this syllabus
document just like you are and I would
interpret it in the way that I think
like for example we could have a look
let's say some of these dot points here
right it says Okay I want students to
understand and use a variety of
notations and representations for
vectors in three dimensions now
something like that
it's not that controversial right and
you may recognize actually if you think
back to our lesson earlier this week
let's just have a quick look through
this right so if you have a look uh this
this is the um
where's my where's my laser pointer
sorry hold on a second
my laser pointer is not working
hold on
how strange
um that's okay I will just draw um if
you have a look here right we've got
component form
ordered triples and column Vector
notation okay now you probably recognize
uh some of them more easily than others
so component form is in terms of this um
these standard unit vectors right so we
actually had a look at some of the some
of that stuff like you know 3i minus 5j
plus 2 K right so in that case you know
which of those is the X component the Y
component the Z component right we also
had a look very briefly at uh column
notation so I would write this same
thing as 3 negative 5 and then two now
you might not have heard the language of
ordered triples before but because it's
the last one of the three can you guys
tell me like what would that look like
how would I write this
three through five with
yep
in the bracket yeah yeah 100 right um so
I would go three comma negative five
comma two good morning Mrs Isles uh
great to have you Earnest um so yeah 100
right and um you're right we would
normally just call these coordinates
however it's a funny thing right the the
word co-ordinates
um technically speaking is not the best
way to do it because like oh code like
is there two of them
um there's actually there's actually
three right so that's part of why they
call them order triples though I
actually think it's in our context
there's no ambiguity like if you called
them
um a 3D coordinate system that's totally
fine right anyway
um the point I wanted to get to is that
let's actually have a look at this is
going to be our Focus for today if you
have a look at I'm going to try and
highlight it like so there we go make it
nice and big for you this second dot
Point here this is what we're going to
have a look at today it says perform
addition and subtraction of
three-dimensional vectors and
multiplication of three-dimensional
vectors I should just highlight those so
this is our arithmetic addition
subtraction multiplication
[Applause]
um of three-dimensional vectors and then
it says we have to remember some of our
language from extension one right it
says by a scalar can you guys help me
remember
um Ryan maybe you could suggest to me
what's the difference between a vector
and a scalar Direction yeah fantastic so
a scalar quantity just gives you size or
magnitude is the other word that we
often use for it and then to get a
vector you just need to add in direction
to that right now we um within the
context of this course we're not going
to be multiplying vectors by vectors
um you might if you guys go and do
mathematics at University you will learn
about what we call the cross product
it's when you have one vector and you
multiply it by another but we're going
to have a look at dot products which is
really about scalar multiplication and
also it says do it algebraically do it
geometrically and then interpret this
right now I was just making a quick note
about the fact that a textbook author if
I were a textbook author I would look at
this and I would say oh here's how I
interpret it right but you guys might
have seen right you've looked at more
than one textbook before
different people will interpret this
slightly differently and so coming back
to the syllabus every single time for
every topic is enormously useful and so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to try
and explain
um one example or one uh context or one
kind of problem that does a really good
job of helping you learn this this skill
that's being talked about here the um
the idea that I'm going to talk about is
not named explicitly anywhere in the
syllabus really at least in this topic
you don't have to learn this but it's a
really good way of doing this and that
is what we call ratio division
now I wonder if uh can you guys give me
an indication do you remember or have
you encountered ratio division in
extension one or even in advanced I
don't think so yeah that's totally fine
it's a I'm gonna introduce this idea to
you we're gonna need to do some drawing
if you've got a rule there will be very
very helpful
um and so uh it's actually it's actually
kind of nice actually that we get to
look at it from sort of a foundation and
then we're going to have a look at how
it applies to 3D vectors because
basically once you learn what ratio
division is you will see how it does
addition and subtraction and
multiplication by a scalar it's kind of
a really good combination of all those
different things rather than just us
saying hey these two vectors and add
them or here's two vectors and subtract
them or just multiply this just because
I told you to right this actually gives
us a reason to do that
all right so the heading is ratio
division now do me a favor and let's
start by uh just just draw me an
interval
um along just like horizontally across
your page
like so
and um by the way you will hear me I'm
going to try and do my best to
distinguish between
um some of the language that we use so
you might hear the word line and the
word interval and that might feel like
the same thing to you but very strictly
speaking a line actually will go forever
so the coordinate axes right they're a
good example of a line they extend out
to Infinity in both directions an
interval by contrast it starts somewhere
and it ends somewhere right so there's a
definite beginning and an end and so you
might realize now a lot of the things
that are intervals you've probably
called Lions right um but but there is
actually a slight Difference by the way
line interval does anyone know it's a
bit of a random one it doesn't come up a
lot but does anyone know what it's
called when you can start somewhere but
actually go forever does anyone know
what that's called starts with an r
yeah I think I heard it right if you
have a starting point but then on in the
opposite direction you go to Infinity we
do call that a array but it doesn't it
comes up very very seldom so don't worry
about it
to get it again that's right okay
so um what we've got here the thing that
you drew with your ruler across your
page is an interval okay so let's call
this interval a b
now the idea of ratio division is we can
divide up this interval into certain
ratios by finding a point somewhere on
it okay now you've already been doing
ratio division a very specific ratio
division without even knowing that
that's what you're doing because in the
previous exercise and Ryan we were
talking about this just before um Sean
arrived you've been asked to do things
like find midpoints for years and years
and years right so if I ask you to find
the midpoint of this order label the
midpoint on it uh let's put it somewhere
around there right so M for midpoint
right
the midpoint is that point on the
interval that divides the interval in a
specific ratio namely a ratio of one to
one right so what I've got there am and
MB obviously they're equal otherwise M
wouldn't be the midpoint okay so what I
would say is that M and it's probably
important that you write down this
underneath because the language is quite
specific actually M divides
a b
in the ratio
one to one
okay now uh this is the simplest case
right but it gets a little more it
starts to get more complex as you start
to do more interesting things with it so
I'm going to cheat a little bit and copy
paste this but if you can do me a favor
make another copy of this interval
um draw me another one
and then what we're going to do is have
a think about different ratios that we
can divide this up into okay so suppose
instead of the ratio one to one I asked
you to do the ratio one to two
hmm so there's going to be some point in
here whereby when I when I place the
point you know the length to the
distance to a is going to be shorter and
the distance to B is going to be longer
and not just like shorter and longer but
one distance is going to be double the
other okay now uh I wonder if you're
having to think about this and realizing
there's a few different challenges here
right the first one is if I say one to
two
uh it doesn't actually it's kind of
implied that either you're going to be
closer to a or you're going to be closer
to B right sorry that's not very
accurate but you get the idea okay now
let me ask you if I told you to divide
the interval a B in the ratio one to two
what is your instinct like if we had to
make up the rules which one would you
say you're closer to a or b
yeah that's exactly right and in fact
this is the convention so if I um get
rid of this second one over here and
place a point here it's not the midpoint
anymore so I'm going to call it P for
Point that's a little more General right
um if this distance here was one in
relation to two this actually is that
one to two ratio okay now suppose you
actually didn't want P to be there
suppose you wanted it to be the other
one right uh this spot over here right
that was closer to B than it was to a
there are actually two ways to describe
that point and to still have the same
kind of information there right this one
of you want to give me a suggestion how
could we
um communicate to someone that we
actually wanted the point closer to B
rather than a what what could you say
Okay so the first way is you could say
uh let's let's do this in Orange over
here we could still say a b but do it in
this ratio two to one so that means the
two is closer to a and the one is closer
to B There is actually one other way
does someone give me a suggestion what
do you think you could do apart from
that
yeah very good so you guys um you guys
are all over this right so um even
though you've never formally encountered
this before uh the order of the ratios
you just look at whichever is the
starting point right so if a is the
starting point you make that the first
part of the ratio if B is the starting
point you make that the first part of
the ratio okay
um so fantastic and you can see here um
sometimes again I'm going to cheat sorry
that I can um I can do this right
um do it quickly um if we go with this
two to one idea right
um another way of saying that is that
you go this distance sort of two hops if
you like and then one hop like so right
so you can literally see
um that there's the two and the one
there right
now another thing that um this sort of
implies is that when you say two to one
or one to two for that matter what
you're really doing is you're breaking
up the interval into uh not just two
equal sections but actually sorry two
sections it's actually three equal
sections can you see that so that two to
one ratio if two pieces are on one side
one piece is on the other then you've
got one two three spots and they are all
equal to each other does that make sense
excellent now um I will do just one last
Quick one here so we've been doing
pretty simple ratio so if I said
something like let's now divide a b in a
ratio like say whoops that's the wrong
spot for the
um colon if I said two to five
two to five so how would I actually
represent this now again I said you know
have a rule there what I would suggest
here is I'm going to use this idea that
I mentioned just up above and say okay
if I'm in the ratio 2 to 5 there are not
going to be three equal sections there
are going to be how many if you combine
them that's seven right so if you can
neatly do maybe you've got a rule there
hopefully if I go sort of one two three
nope that's not that's that's too close
too far apart all right two three that's
more like it one two three there we go
okay so can you see here I've got my one
two three four five six seven equal
sections and so to go two to five you
can see I'm going to here and then five
oh let's try that again
that's a bit better here so you can see
where P would end up because of where it
does the ratio so far so good